there's something that I'd like you to
see it's a story that's deeply unsettled
millions in China footage of a
two-year-old girl hit by a van and left
bleeding in the street by passers-by
footage too graphic to be shown the
entire accident is caught on camera
the driver pauses after hitting the
child his back wheels seen resting on
her for over a second within two minutes
three people passed two-year-old when
you buy the first walks around the badly
injured toddler completely others look
at her before moving off there were
other people who walk past weighing you
and a second van ran over her legs
before a street cleaner raised the alarm
she was rushed to hospital but it was
too late she died I wonder how many of
you looking at that said to yourselves
just now I would not have done that I
would have stopped to help raise your
hands if that thought occurred to you as
I thought that's most of you and I
believe you I'm sure you're right
but before you give yourself too much
credit look at this unicef reports that
in 2011 six point nine million children
under five died from preventable poverty
related diseases unicef thinks that
that's good news because the figure has
been steadily coming down from 12
million in 1990 that is good but still
six point nine million is 19 thousand
children dying every day does it really
matter that we're not walking past them
in the street does it really matter that
they're far away i don't think it does
make a morally relevant difference the
fact that they're not right in front of
us in fact of course they're of a
different nationality or ray
none of that seems morally relevant to
me what is really important is can we
reduce that death toll can we save some
of those 19 thousand children dying
every day and the answer is yes we can
each of us spends money on things that
we do not really need you can think what
your own habit is whether it's a new car
a vacation or just something like buying
bottled water when the water that comes
out of the tap is perfectly safe to
drink you could take the money you're
spending on those unnecessary things and
give it to this organization the against
malaria foundation which would take the
money you were given and use it to buy
nets like this one to protect children
like this one and we know reliably that
if we provide Nets they're used and they
reduce the number of children dying from
malaria just one of the many preventable
diseases that are responsible for some
of those 19,000 children dying every day
fortunately more and more people are
understanding this idea and the result
is a growing movement effective altruism
it's important because it combines both
the heart and the head the heart of
course you felt you felt the empathy for
that child but it's really important to
use the head as well to make sure that
what you do is effective and well
directed and not only that but also I
think reason helps us to understand that
other people wherever they are are like
us that they can suffer as we can but
parents grieve for the deaths of their
children as we do and that just as our
lives and our well-being matters to us
it matters just as much to all of these
people so I think reason is not just
some neutral tool to help you get
whatever you want it does help us to put
perspective on
situation and I think that's why many of
the most significant people in effective
altruism have been people who have had
backgrounds in philosophy or economics
or math and that might seem surprising
because a lot of people think philosophy
is remote from the real world economics
we're told just makes us more selfish
and we know that math is for nerds but
in fact it does make a difference and in
fact there's one particular nerd who has
been a particularly effective altruist
because he got this this is the website
of the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and if you look at the words on the top
right hand side it says all lives have
equal value that's the understanding the
rational understanding of our situation
in the world that has led to these
people being the most effective
altruists in history Bill and Melinda
Gates and Warren Buffett
no one not Andrew Carnegie not john d
rockefeller has ever given as much to
charity as each one of these three and
they have used their intelligence to
make sure that it is highly effective
according to one estimate the Gates
Foundation has already saved 5.8 million
lives and many millions more people
getting diseases that would have made
them very sick
even if eventually they survived over
the coming years undoubtedly the Gates
Foundation is going to give a lot more
is going to save a lot more lives well
you might say that's fine if you're a
billionaire you can have that kind of
impact but if I'm not what can I do so
I'm going to look at four questions that
people ask that maybe stand in the way
of them giving they worry how much of a
difference they can make but you don't
have to be a billionaire this is Toby
Ord he's a research fellow in philosophy
at the University of Oxford he became an
effective altruist when he calculated
that with the money that he was likely
to earn throughout his career an
academic career he could give enough to
cure 80,000 people of blindness in
developing countries and still have
enough left for a perfectly adequate
standard of living
so Toby founded an organization called
giving what we can to spread this
information to unite people who want to
share some of their income and to ask
people to pledge to give 10% of what
they earn over their lifetime to
fighting global poverty
Toby himself does better than that he's
pledged to live on 18,000 pounds a year
that's less than $30,000 and to give the
rest to those organizations and yes Toby
is married and he does have a mortgage
this is a couple at a later stage of
life
Charlie Bressler and Diana shot who when
they were young when they met were
activists against the Vietnam War fought
for social justice and then moved into
careers as most people do didn't really
do anything very active about those
values although they didn't abandon them
and then as they got to the age at which
many people start to think of retirement
they returned to them and they've
decided to cut back on their spending to
live modestly and to give both money and
time to helping to fight global poverty
now mentioning time might lead you to
think well should I abandon my career
and put all of my time into saving some
of these 19,000 lives that are lost
every day one person who's thought quite
a bit about this issue of how you can
have a career that will have the biggest
impact for good in the world is will
Crouch he's a graduate student in
philosophy and he set up a website
called 80,000 hours the number of hours
he estimates most people spend on their
career to advise people on how to have
the best most effective career but you
might be surprised to know that one of
the careers that he encourages people to
consider if they have the right
abilities and character is to go into
banking or finance why because if you
earn a lot of money you can give away a
lot of money and if you're successful in
that career you could give enough to an
aid organization so that it could employ
let's say five aid workers in developing
countries and each one of them would
probably do about as much good as you
would have done so you can quintuple the
impact by leading that kind of career
here's one young man who's taken this
advice his name is Matt Wagga he was a
student at Princeton and philosophy and
math actually won the prize for the best
undergraduate philosophy thesis last
year when he graduated but he's gone
into finance in New York he's already
earning enough
so that he's giving a six-figure sum to
effective charities and still leaving
himself with enough to live on Matt has
also helped me to set up an organization
that I'm working with that has the name
taken from the title of a book I wrote
the life you can save which is trying to
change our culture so that more people
think that if we're going to live an
ethical life it's not enough just to
follow the thou shalt nots and not cheat
steal maim kill but that if we have
enough we have to share some of that
with people who have so little and the
organization draws together people of
different generations like Polly Morgan
who's an undergraduate who's pledged to
give 10% of the little amount that she
has and on the right 8:01 who has worked
directly for the poor but has now gone
to Yale to do an MBA to have more to
give many people will think though that
charities aren't really all that
effective so let's talk about
effectiveness Toby Ord is very concerned
about this and he's calculated that some
charities are hundreds or even thousands
of times more effective than others so
it's very important to find the
effective ones take for example
providing a guide dog for a blind person
that's a good thing to do right all
right it is a good thing to do but you
have to think what else you could do
with the resources it cost about forty
thousand dollars to train a guide dog
and train the recipient so that the
guide dog can be an effective help to a
blind person
it cost somewhere between twenty and
fifty dollars to cure a blind person in
a developing country if they have
trachoma so you do the sums and you get
something like that you could provide
one guide dog for one blind american or
you could cure between four hundred and
two thousand people of blindness i think
it's clear what's the better thing to do
but if you want to look for effective
charities this is a good website to go
to
give well exist to really assess the
impact of charities not just where they
run well run and it's screened hundreds
of charities and currently is
recommending only three of which the
against malaria foundation is number one
so it's very tough if you want to look
for other recommendations the life you
can save calm and giving what we can
both have a somewhat broader list but
you can find effective organizations and
not just in the area of saving lives
from the poor I'm pleased to say that
there are now also a website looking at
effective animal organizations
that's another cause that I've been
concerned about all my life the immense
amount of suffering that humans inflict
on literally tens of billions of animals
every year so if you want to look for
effective organizations to reduce that
suffering you can go to effective animal
activism and some effective altruists
think it's very important to make sure
that our species survives at all so
they're looking at ways to reduce the
risk of extinction here's one risk of
extinction that we all became aware of
recently when an asteroid passed close
to our planet
possibly research could help us not only
to predict the path of asteroids that
might collide with us but actually to
deflect them so some people think that
would be a good thing to give - there's
many possibilities my final question is
some people will think it's a burden to
give I don't really believe it is I've
enjoyed giving all of my life since I
was a graduate student it's been
something fulfilling to me Charlie
Bressler said to me that he's not an
altruist he thinks that the life he's
saving is his own and Holly Morgan told
me that she used to battle depression
until she got involved with effective
altruism and now is one of the happiest
people she knows I think one of the
reasons for this is that being an
effective altruists
helps to overcome what I call the
Sisyphus problem his Sisyphus is
portrayed by titian condemned by the
gods to push a huge boulder up to the
top of the hill just as he gets there
the effort becomes too much the
all their escapes rolls all the way down
the hill he has to trudge back up back
down to push it up again and the same
thing happens again and again for all
eternity does that remind you of a
consumer lifestyle where you you work
hard to get money you spend that money
on consumer goods which you hope you'll
enjoy using but then the money's gone
you have to work hard to get more spend
more and to maintain the same level of
happiness it's kind of a hedonic
treadmill you never get off and you
never really feel satisfied becoming an
effective altruist gives you that
meaning and fulfillment it enables you
to have a solid basis for self-esteem on
which you can feel your life was really
worth living I'm going to conclude by
telling you about an email that I
received while I was writing this letter
just this talk just a month or so ago
from a man named Chris Croix who I'd
never heard of this is a picture of him
showing him recovering from surgery
why was he recovering from surgery the
email began last Tuesday I anonymously
donated my right kidney to a stranger
that started a kidney chain which
enabled for people to receive kidneys
there's about a hundred people each year
in the US and more in other countries
who do that I was pleased to read it
Chris went on to say that he'd been
influenced by my writings in what he did
well I have to admit I'm also somewhat
embarrassed by that because I still have
two kidneys but Chris went on to say
that he didn't think that what he done
was all that amazing because he
calculated that the number of life years
that he had added to people the
extension of life was about the same
that you could achieve if you gave
$5,000 to the against malaria foundation
and that did make me feel a little bit
better because I have given more than
$5,000 to the against malaria foundation
and to various other
effective charities so if you're feeling
bad because you still have two kidneys
as well there's a way for you to get off
the hook thank you
[Applause]